i've got some firepower in my talk at
the table i got some video
help so it's about children and what
they are saying as they
go back to school during the pandemic so
the big picture is 56 million
k-12 students are returning this fall
either remotely or in person
or by blending the two approaches so
what we did is we spoke to some children
for our school
matters series here's what they said
we're excited to go back to school
how do you feel i'm excited to get back
to school too i'm concerned about recess
and how seeing my friends is gonna work
and wearing maskable social distancing
it's not gonna be as fun you have to
wear a shield for the whole school class
and when you leave you can take it off
i'm also concerned about my experience
this will be my last year of high school
so i know that i won't be getting the
same experience as a lot of seniors
before me
why can't we go and see our friends why
can't we go to school
why do we have to do this
online learning stuff and
how's this going to help us my dude i uh
my teachers again i think the teachers
might be
a little like nervous maybe a little bit
they don't want to get sick
so yeah it's what i'm a little bit
nervous of students might find it more
easier or more difficult to learn
through online schooling
so will colleges look at this year more
lenient or more stricter when it comes
to
our outcomes of this year i feel like my
grades are gonna
like draw because i'm gonna be so
used to online school that i forget how
to um
do in person school which is actually
the normal
thing
nothing against teenagers but the
eight-year-olds and the four-year-old
gavin when can i hug my teacher
or grace or grace my sister lenny
teaches elementary school and she said
it's very hard when you're just dealing
with a computer screen because some of
them will just get up and walk away yeah
they just they've had enough they just
get up and walk away i like that
reflective eight-year-old i think my
grades may drop
yes yes they're very worried we get it
all right get it it's new for listen as
as hard as it is for them it's new for
everybody yeah we're all in the same
sustaining it is really hard you know i
think everybody thought going into the
summer maybe things would be better in
the fall and now here
you know a lot of kids are going through
it all over again that's the problem
there doesn't seem to be an
end in sight that's what's so concerning
this too shall pass
i believe that i do actually do believe
that
moments ago we heard from children
talking about their concerns about
returning to school during this very
unusual time in the pandemic
we're going to stick with that
psychologist and cbs news contributor
lisa damore joins us now
to answer questions and concerns from
those students lisa good morning to you
this is a really interesting
conversation and and i think
colin here in montana who we have a
question from really
sums it up when he says he's going back
to school uh
in person and like a lot of kids i think
he's con
he's concerned about the social
distancing he says he's scared his
school will feel like a jail
cold and distant what's your advice for
students confronting
that kind of experience when they go
back
well colin's right school is going to
feel different this year you know
everyone's going to be wearing masks
there's going to be plexiglass in all
sorts of new places everyone's going to
be kept at a distance from one another
but i think colin's already doing
something that will help him which is to
think about what he's walking into
because any time we're walking into a
situation that's difficult
the more we imagine it the more we
prepare ourselves mentally
the better it actually goes when we get
there so anticipating those changes and
being ready for them will make a big
difference
the other thing i would say though to
students is that
their teachers want school to be a warm
and friendly place
and i know teachers are going to do
everything in their power to make
students feel connected
and calm and cared for even while
following all of those safety
precautions part of keeping a school
a warm and friendly place can mean a
high five it can mean a hug i mean in
the old days
now we heard from one little guy gavin
age four he said when am i gonna be able
to hug my teacher again
what do you say to kids like that
well i think we tell them the truth we
say well we don't know
but until you can hug your teacher there
are lots of other ways that you can show
them
how much they mean to you and be
affectionate with them
so maybe you'll come up with some funny
little wave or some special wink that
you give each other over your masks
you can still have that kind of fun
playful
affection until we can hug again
extracurriculars are also coming up a
lot we heard from two kids who were
wondering is it safe to play sports and
then beyond sports there's a million
after-school things that kids do
what's the advice to those kids who are
weighing the risks and benefits of
getting involved with clubs with theater
all of that this is a tough one
because nothing matters more than safety
and
there may be things that kids cannot do
safely maybe sports or other kinds of
theatrical activities
but what we should tell young people is
that doesn't mean
that they can't find ways to develop
those skills to build themselves as
athletes to build themselves in the
other things they would have worked on
after school and they may even be able
to get together with their peers in a
safe way
to do those things until the more
traditional systems by which we do that
can come back
when you start talking about the older
kids high school age they're thinking
about college they're thinking about the
rest of their lives
this would be a time when they're
volunteering when they're doing things
to build their resume for that
all-important application
now they can't and they're nervous about
that what would you say to them
here's what i'm saying to young people
you know the bad news is this pandemic
affects everybody
the better news is colleges know it
affects everybody
so what i am telling young people is to
do what they can
with what they have where they are you
know this is a time to be resourceful
so it may be that young people develop
you know a digital tutoring service for
the kids in their community
or painters get really serious about
their artwork
and find other ways you know all
students have ways to cultivate their
intellectual lives
that's what colleges are going to want
to see they're going to want to see that
you did what you could
even within the limits placed upon you
lisa can i just say your voice is so
soothing i don't know if i'm just
noticing it for the first time but it's
so soothing but
in our last hour we had a great story
about a little boy named rocco 11 years
old
who said that he was depressed number
one i think it's great that he's
speaking publicly on national tv with
his mom and his dad
and that his mom said you know this
isn't something i ever thought i'd have
to deal with
you know kids suffering from depression
at such an early age
what question should parents be asking
should children be asking
how can we help them through this
you know we should expect some sadness
these are hard times
and feeling down about them is not a
sign that there's something wrong it's
actually a sign that you're having the
right feeling at the right time
so i don't want parents to be worried if
their kids are feeling sad about the
things they're missing out on or about
school being different
but mood should go up and down kids
should have sad moments and then they
should recover
and they should feel good again we worry
when mood gets low
and stays low in teenagers we worry if
they are
cranky all the time that is actually
sometimes what depression looks like in
teenagers
if a parent is worried they should
absolutely consult with their physician
or a mental health professional
to check things out lisa how do you deal
with the
with with the sort of the constantly
changing landscape we're looking at
right now i mean
a lot of kids were told they'd be going
back into the class then all of a sudden
the school changed its mind
it's shifting all the time it we're all
dealing with it but i think
that's really kids are used to routine
they're usually trying we try to give
them a routine they need routines yeah
you know i think it's pretty good to
think two weeks out you know what is
this week looking to look like maybe
what is next week going to look like and
even within those
short time frames to create routines
that in the day-to-day there can be some
predictability
even if there can't be predictability
over a broader scope
and one of the things i love about kids
and teenagers is they are flexible
they're actually more flexible than
grown-ups
so if the grown-ups can have some
confidence that kids will figure this
out and be able to adapt as this
continues to change on this
on all of us i think kids will figure it
out and we can count on them for that
all right lisa i think you're leaving
everyone feeling a lot calmer this year
we appreciate that
much the job to help people feel good
that's what psychologists are supposed
to do
well mission accomplishments bravo